aujourd'hui il y à des opérations de
nettoyage dont irvine les ukrainiens
pense qu'il doit y avoir encore des
combattants russes dans la ville
peut-être aussi des mines et des
beaucoup de raisons pourquoi ils ne
peuvent pas admettre les civils dans
here pin tout de suite mais après
l'annnonce du maire hier dans l'après
midi il y a eu le président ukrainien
qui le confirme des photos sans sortie
de soldats ukrainien dans here pin en
train de fêter leur victoire et des
experts américains aussi confirme que
les ukrainiens sont bel et bien à
nouveau on contrôle dire pin des experts
américains je voulais dire les
renseignements britanniques pour leur
part sont un peu plus
ne vont pas jusqu'à affirmer
haut et fort que here pin est aux mains
des ukrainiens mais ils disent que les
ukrainiens mènent des opérations de
contre attaque avec succès à différents
endroits de la région je pense que pour
aussi mettre un peu d'eau dans le vin
ici il ne convient de rappeler que mac
arrive une autre ville à l'ouest de kiev
qui avait été prise par les russes puis
reprise par les ukrainiens a été
bombardé cette nuit avec des missiles un
multiple de type grad donc on ne peut
jamais et très sûr que les et russes ne
vont pas essayer de mener des opérations
de revanche alors je pense que la
situation la sécurité à irvine et bien c
est pour le moment loin d'être sûr